well apparently it was all pretend when
nancy pelosi played nice with
the squad a new book revealing how the
speaker truly feels
about the band of radical lawmakers
pelosi unloading on the group for always
trying to grab
attention and saying quote you're not a
one-person show
this is the congress of the united
states and pelosi used a mocking
childlike voice when discussing the
socialist congresswoman
aoc so maybe she was up talking dana
when she was discussing
the squad you know nancy pelosi is an
institutionalist
not surprising that she would be
frustrated with this left wing of her
party
well remember the very first day that
aoc was there in congress she led a
a protest and sit in in nancy pelosi's
office to talk about climate change
uh something i find kind of interes i
think this whole dynamic is interesting
you know we're living through
two political realignments all at once
it's pretty interesting to see
um and yes you're right nancy pelosi has
been there for a long time she's like
that's not how we're going to be able to
get things done but she's been able to
actually
hold on to power and she has a pretty
good grip on her caucus however
if you remember there are many times
that she has basically
given aoc and the squad what they want
in one of the coveted relief bills
remember the one that got so huge and
got so ridiculous and they added all
this green new deal stuff to it
including um making airlines
report their emissions and this is
supposed to be in a covered relief bill
this is the
very beginning when there was all that
panic and worry
so i think that in a way she has only
herself to blame that the squad
continues to get a little bit more
strong and the other thing is she also
needs them
they are the grassroots oh i should i
should ask richard to talk about this
but to me they
um really energize the grassroots and
when you're talking about fundraising
where does all that small dollar
donation come from the grassroots and
and she has that in spades aoc does
but doesn't the squad jesse really own
the agenda that we're seeing including
in the white house
well if you look at what's coming out of
the white house yes
but i'd have to ask aoc aoc you're going
to take that
are you going to let nancy get away with
that i don't think she's going to take
that laying down and i'm going to be
delighted when this erupts into a huge
brawl
no but in all seriousness i think that
aoc actually listened to nancy
and dialed it back a little bit and now
is playing the inside game she's got the
house progressive caucus
under her thumb she's working her
coalition she's got
people in committees that are they're
not trying to just blow things up and
hold bills hostage and
make people pay ransoms she's trying to
strategically move things in a left
direction without blowing them up so
that's mature
and as someone who's also matured in
their professional career i
tip my hat to aoc but i don't think it's
going to last
because once the midterms roll around
she's not going to be able to help
herself she'll start bomb throwing and
primary
moderates and that'll just delight me
and i can't wait to cover it
yep yeah greg isn't this just a perfect
inside view of how dc works they all get
along on the outside but behind the
scenes they hate each other
yeah and it just reminds me of a really
bad
superhero movie in which you find the
heroes and the villains
equally annoying i don't know who to
back in this fight
i don't like anything about the story
it's just i
this is more evidence of the trump-size
hole
right it's like you need this like this
weird little
conflict to just fill part of that hole
that trump
left i mean it's safe to say that all
politicians suck
and they suck because the variables of
importance have changed
it used to be you employed politicians
to help people
now we employ people to help politicians
so i have no sympathy for any of these
people
uh and um yeah i
i honestly find them reprehensible
i have no feeling good feelings for any
of them
and i don't have any good feelings for
jesse either i have no good feelings for
jesse
that's that's not very nice is that what
you said last night
i was drunk oh all right all right
richard last word to you for sure thanks
katie listen i i
weirdly and oddly i find myself agreeing
with jesse on this one i think that uh
aoc
aoc has learned a lot from uh speaker
pelosi but i think
i know i know a lot of folks in our
viewing audience is not that they're not
the biggest fans of speaker pelosi but
she's been a very effective speaker when
it comes to moving legislation
and keeping her caucus together and
maybe aoc is sort of saying hey maybe
follow nancy pelosi as the way to go
because she's an effective leader
and she's more effective than previous
speakers of the house so there you have
it
well maybe they're not going to be on
the cover rolling stone together anymore
such a shame